fashion goddess is the best way to
describe Megan Markel and we have no
doubt that our baby will be just as
stylish here's a look at how the Duchess
might dress her royal offspring for
starters Megan's considered a very
modern royal especially when it comes to
her attire Megan has ruffles inside this
is quite different it's fresh it's
modern it's a bit new great set of legs
no tights a pretty short skirt that she
was wearing as well you know this is
Megan's style this is Megan's way Megan
will decide how she dresses bebe Sussex
- a move very different from
sister-in-law Kate Middleton the Duchess
of Cambridge clothes George Charlotte
and Louie in pretty traditional attire
most likely because of their daddy's
direct line to the throne
so Rachel Riley pepping company amaya
kids and Dona Carmen are a few
children's clothing designers who fit
the bill according to etiquette expert
William Hanson heat has to find a
balance between royal tradition heritage
and more proletariat customs such as the
suburban habit of making young boys wear
trousers that means lots of shorts for
Prince George just like his dad and
uncle wore when they were young Hanson
explained that boys normally graduate to
trousers around 8 years old quote it's a
very English thing to dress a young boy
in shorts trousers are for older boys
and men wear our shorts on young boys is
one of those silent class markers that
we have in England Megan broke tradition
at our wedding opting for George and the
other page boys to wear miniature
versions of the Blues and Royals frock
coat and trousers worn by Harry and
William and according to one report the
Duchess is determined her child won't be
paraded around in little shorts like
Prince George of course we still have no
idea whether baby Sussex is a boy or a
girl
Kensington Palace are saying that the
couple don't know the sex of the baby
there were some rumors
out of that infamous baby shower in New
York that she was openly telling people
that she's expecting a boy who knows the
truth is we don't really have very long
to wait to find out whether they're
having a boy or a girl
which means Megan and Harry are probably
is stocking up on gender-neutral onesies
similar to the decor in the baby's
nursery don't expect to see any baby
pink or baby blue apparently is going to
be a monochrome palette and whites and
grays I'm told will be the color theme
for baby saw sixes nursery and
considering Megan love for a mixture of
high and low end threads for herself
it's likely she'll do the same for her
child H&M is one of her favorites that
has a kid's line too we regularly see
the Duchess rocking a pair of Aqua Zara
heels and now they have a darling line
of little girl's shoes Dior is another
high-end fashion house that offers
everything from quilted pajamas to
pint-sized trousers the adventure of a
lifetime one thing is for sure no matter
what the Royal baby is wearing the
clothes will sell out in minutes